so jackie
you we we just heard you have some
breaking news for us give us the latest
i do breaking news is that vincent joe
will not be competing in the men's shore
program tomorrow so
he's done um for the individual event
it's it's just really unfortunate
um and i think about
what's been happening too like he's been
here for what 10 11 days he's one of the
people who
consistently wears masks on practices i
i just don't know i i i have no idea
like it's it's just crazy
well i know that nathan has been in
close contact with vincent i'm praying
there's never been anything you know
going on as far as exposure or anything
else but how is nathan continuing to
look in practice have you been tracking
his jumps and tracking all of his
demeanor on the ice how does he look
well the the interesting thing is i
i i don't know if it's me projecting or
other people also projecting but it just
feels like after he hit that clean short
in the team event his practices snapped
into a very different rhythm and then
today and we'll talk about this in a
little bit but today when yuzuru hanyu
finally arrived and came on practice it
snapped into yet another level and and
uh
sort of like intensity about what he was
doing but it was just it was a focused
intensity it was really just like
that's the nathan i i'm so used to
seeing at world championships doing
you know clean run-throughs just you
know drilling his jumps the way that he
wants to and and he's rounding out into
form
you know it's um the thing about vince
and joe as well it's too late to call in
ilya mullin and who skated lights out at
the national championships whose is
alternate so that's sad but um hey i was
at the first practice for nancy nancy
and tonya in lillehammer and hanyu just
arrived and i understand that it was
quite the fiasco at his first practice
so i wouldn't call it a fiasco it was
actually a very controlled environment
so covet protocols right um four years
ago i remember when i was in pyeongchang
it was when you went to the practice
ring it was literally just like stuffed
everybody was there everybody was just
kind of sitting on top of each other
here the practice rank there's very
little media seating i think it was like
maximum capacity was 30 people
and so what happened today was basically
um all the all the journalists went and
basically camped out over there during
the team event and by the time you know
i think probably by the time an hour
before the team event ended the practice
rank was already full with journalists
and and so um it got to be basically
impossible to get in there so um luckily
i had some folks in there who who are
trusted sources who are able to give me
some intel there was also streaming on
peacock
some live practice uh stuff go so i i
was able to take advantage of those two
and kind of piece all the practices
together
you